Speaker 1: folks.
The Spanish channel is now live.
We have launched the David Pakman show in
Spanish or we might call it the David Pakman
show in Espanol.
You can find this new channel at YouTube.
Now, listen very carefully here, okay?
Because you URLs can't contain that little
that goes above the end in some Spanish words.
So you go to YouTube.com slash at symbol David
Pakman Espanol, not Espanol Espanol.
Okay.
I know it's the best we could do with the
URL.
This channel is our next project to reach
Spanish speaking American residents.
Of course, everyone is free to watch.
One of the things I hear all the time and
experienced personally when I did the Spanish
show around the time of the 2020 election
is that there is a dearth of progressive opinion
content in Spanish about American politics.
Yeah.
In Argentina, you can find a thousand shows
about Argentinean politics in Mexico.
You can find a thousand shows about Mexican
politics.
But so many of you write to me and say, David,
I'm first generation, second generation, whatever.
I like watching news and politics in English.
My parents like watching in Spanish.
We need something like The David Pakman Show
in Spanish.
The right has tons of Spanish language talk
radio spreading conspiracy theories about
everything from vaccines to Jews and everything
in between.
Okay, so the reason we're doing this and it's
not cheap is because it is necessary.
It is necessary to do it.
So.
Tell people who prefer to consume content
in Spanish that this is now available.
YouTube.com slash at David Pakman ISP A.L.
OC.
If you want to help us just by subscribing
as well.
Even if you're not looking for the Spanish,
great.
We are under a thousand subscribers on this,
but I think that this could be absolutely
huge.
And remember that we do fund this entire project.
We have to pay for the dubbing, okay?
We have to pay for that upfront.
And it's at a loss because obviously the channel
is just starting The David Pakman Show memberships
do fund all of the stuff that we're doing,
including this new Spanish project, which
I think is just so important and could be
so important to actually electing progressive
candidates.
We need to be reaching the Spanish speaking
audience and it's an amazing thing to be doing.
So super, super exciting now.
One thing I will mention, people have already
started to write to me and they say, David,
you speak Spanish.
You should be just doing this.
All of the segments over again in Spanish.
I can't do it.
Okay, I'm out of time for the day.
I just do not have the time between all of
my current responsibilities, filming the show,
working with our team to get everything out.
Short form content, live streams, running
the business, the baby at home, all these
different things.
I can't also now start doing my show in Spanish,
so I know there are people who would rather
me do the Spanish language stuff.
It's just exceeds the number of hours in the
day.
So that is not going to be part of the plan.
But I think this is a really great thing.
Let's do it.
Let's check it out.
Let me know what you think.